six one seven eight three zero forty
seven fifty is the number let's try
why don't we go to the 803 area code 803
if you're calling from 803 introduce
yourself
hey David my name is Matt go ahead Matt
so my question is I guess about money in
politics I see a lot of like prominent
left-wing figures when they talk about
it they seem to believe that like
special interest groups will approach
politician and you know give them
campaign contributions to adopt their
position but I see a lot of like for
Scott with Scott Pruett for example I
think he's inclined to believe that like
climate change is a hoax on his own I
don't think that he needs the oil and
gas industry to lead him to that
conclusion my question is what do you
think it's more common for special
interest to coerce candidates to adopt
their position or you think it's more
common for special interests to approach
candidates who already share their
position right so I think coerces may be
the wrong word I think what you have is
a situation much more nuanced here's how
I see it certainly there is no question
that if you want I don't know a let's
just pick an issue like let's imagine
gay marriage we're an issue that right
now
special interests were making campaign
donations about you're not gonna go to
Bernie or Elizabeth Warren and start
giving them money if you're lobbying
against gay marriage with the idea that
they'll change their mind and now be
against gay marriage right you're gonna
go to the people that you think are
positioned to be the best advocates for
your position you're gonna go to Ted
Cruz or whatever right-wing nut you can
find that's against gay marriage and
you're gonna prop them up because the
more power they have the more money they
have the better position they will be to
do your bidding for you but that's not
the only scenario because that's sort of
the argument that a lot of times doctors
make around receiving money from big
pharmaceutical companies they go listen
I'd be recommending all of this stuff
anyway well then why are you getting any
money at all they're not just rewarding
you if they're not getting anything out
of it they wouldn't give you the money
so there is also the sort of
softer long-term influence of seeing an
industry as your benefactor and even at
the subconscious level being more
favorable to them so it's a spectrum I
think would be my answer Matt okay thank
you all right no problem thank you very
very good questions today pithy and
straightforward and the entire thing